delegates arrived in the capital bamako
for the talks organized by mali's
government dominated by military leaders
the four-day forum is aiming to pave the
way for the return of civilian role
following last year's call
mali's transitional government expects
delegates to make concrete proposals for
ending the political crisis
and to prevent further sanctions from
the regional organization a course
this is our country they can't wish for
the good of our country more than we
do mali has a long history of national
consultations to discuss problems and
recommend solutions
but this time the opposition aren't
attending insisting it was a waste of
time they are demanding a swift return
to democratic rule
but some delegates disagree
it is not possible to hold elections
the people of mali have suffered
political instability since gaining
independence from france 61 years ago
in august last year the military toppled
president ibrahim buba kaketa after
weeks of street protests against
corruption and insecurity
another coup in may
disrupted the military's pledge for
elections in february
no group has claimed responsibility for
wednesday's attack in nara town on the
border with mauritania
it's a potential victim in four sau
we need to dialogue with them exchange
with them to disarm their hearts and
minds as long as we don't do that as
soon as they have an occasion they will
attack
attacks by and groups in the restive
sahel desert region have killed
thousands and displaced millions despite
years of efforts by international forces
to defeat them
it's feared further attacks will cause
yet more instability
fidelis
al jazeera abuja